elon's tough because a lot of people  hate that guy but I can't figure out why  you know if you're like ah like a lot of  progressive people hate Elon but I'm  like hey you know you're [ __ ] on an  African-American over here  Kardashian hey that's a fun one all  right all right well uh  you know Pete Davidson's in there now  which is impressive because hey that's a  comedian and he's gentrifying her vagina  which is uh you know  [Applause]  it's usually a lot of black in there and  you know Whitey came in and uh had to  had to clean up the neighborhood you  know  uh that's exciting yeah  Kardashians are fun there's like eight  of them I like them they're they're  they're fun they're [ __ ] they have  fake asses that's cool and they made a  career out of it good for them I say  I'm I'm a fan I'm a fan cancel culture  yeah yeah yeah that's a tough one well  this set won't help me on that uh